almost 3 years ago in December of 2020
time published an article announcing
that America's racial Reckoning had made
its way into high school debate leagues
time reports with of course total
approval and admiration that debate
competitions have now become forums for
confronting the horrors of systemic
racism we talk about one high school one
high school debater named bintu basemore
who was preparing for her next
tournament quote for the team's first
tournament this school year which will
be held virtually in January by Emory uh
University high school debate
tournaments are typically hosted by
colleges basemore is getting ready to
try out her most daring speech yet the
teenager plans to talk about how black
women are often left out of the
conversation when it comes to mental
health quote I'm an African-American
female look at me she says in one
version of the speech she's rehearsing
when you see me up here what do you
think strong independent gold digger
poor crazy this is not the typical stuff
of O of oratory meets where even
speeches about the most hot button
topics are studiously mild quote a lot
of speeches I hear they're good but they
don't seem real basemore says if I'm
going to say something I'm going to say
it from the heart if I'm the only black
female in the room what I say
matters you have to hand it to her she
has come up with two short sentences
that perfectly encapsulate the left-wing
attitude on Race I am a black female
look at me that kind of says it all I
suppose but this was not a momentary
blip on the radar high school debate did
not Veer off into racial Insanity only
to correct itself and get back to doing
what high school debate is supposed to
do which by the way is to teach kids how
to successfully argue for a position
using logic and reason now apparently
and not surprisingly things have only
gotten worse in the world of high school
debate since 2020 a guy named James
Fishback is the founder of an
organization called incubate debate
which is a new and uh fast growing
debate league that focuses on it says
civility Merit and open debate which
sets it apart from most other debate
leagues these days that evidently focus
on none of those things Jam Jes has been
keeping track of and Reporting on the
radical woke aying of high school debate
uh one video he posted a few days ago
shows reading from his caption quote a
high school debate team winning the
national championship by not debating
the assigned topic and ranting about
trans genocide
instead there's a lot of these kinds of
videos kids in the middle of a debate
meet uh or whatever you're supposed to
call it uh decide I'm not going to talk
about the topic at hand instead I'm
going to talk about trans people I'm
going to talk about racism in a video
posted a few days before that we see a
nationally ranked High School debater
arguing that the other team's points are
invalid because their team has a white
debater watch they have a white debater
on their team which inherently means
they have more whiteness than us we
obviously know that not white it's
pretty obvious go down onto our pick we
give you three warrants why we subsume
all of their protests and affirm their
protest in a pick what it means is you
are furthering their cause just minus
the whiteness as is a vehicle for this
Movement we say whiteness is really bad
for representation in queer people and
it's a bad form of furthering this
protest the best way to further the
protest is to vote for our pick and to
affirm it but minus the whiteness they
say that we're taking over labor but
first this is a new response if they
read this response before we probably
would have read a capc about how you
can't like use labor across identity
lines that's a really bad thing to do
second how PS work is you affirm their
protest we're not taking over their
labor it's just a technicality of debate
then they say that it's trans exclusion
no couple responses that they from one
our constructive speech was about
personal experiences about our identity
we are not comfortable discussing our
sexuality on a live stream with a 130
people second we say that like um them
telling us how we should represent our
advocacy feeds into our link about
racism because a white person someone on
a white team should never be telling two
women of color how they should be
furthering their advocacy that's an
independent linking to our whiteness
argument that gets dropped you can drop
them right
now
um now I I just want to highlight that's
debate that's what a debate and and we
blurred to faces because these are kids
you know it's high school kids and the
the point here like the point is what is
being done to these kids actually it's
not
to humiliate the kids themselves but uh
it's a very sad thing in fact because it
shows what is being done to them in
these schools which we'll get into in a
minute but I just want to highlight one
sentence from that die tribe which is
nearly impossible to translate into
English especially this part quote
whiteness means really bad for
representation in queer people and it's
a bad form of furthering this
protest now most people will focus on
how woke all this is but the greater
concern is that it is totally
incoherent apparently you can win a high
school debate tournament Now by
stringing together a series of leftist
buzzword without even bothering to
connect those words in a way that makes
sense forget about saying things that
are that are wrong well I can't even I
can't even listen to that and say she's
wrong because it doesn't mean anything
that nothing there is no premise here
there's no uh uh proposition being made
there's no there's nothing there's no
argument being
presented it's it's just nonsense you
know the holidays are coming up fast and
while you're out shopping for your kids
family and friends don't forget to shop
for your pets too give your dog the gift
of a healthier and happier life with
rough greens naturopathic Dr Dennis
black uh the founder of Ru greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America before I started feeding
my dog Ruff greens I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it contains very
little nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you can just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for our dogs too naturopathic
Dr Dennis black is so confident rough
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it
get a free jump start trial bag
delivered straight to your door in just
a few business days go to Ru greens.com
or call 844 ru700 that's rfffg
greens.com or call 844 ru700 today
keeping your windshields clean is always
a pain the dirt easily piles up and
washer fluid just can't get the job done
that's why uh my friends at windshield
wow come in to save the day windshield
wow is an Innovative windshield cleaning
device that uses two magnetic cleaning
paddles one on the outside and one on
the inside of your car to clean both
sides of a windshield all from the
outside all you do is uh push around the
outside paddle and the inside follows
and cleans the inside automatically
leaving your windshield squeaky clean
here in Nashville and many parts of the
country we are starting to get a lot of
rain and with that you get this hazy and
dirty windshield throw one of these in
the back of your car so you can always
have a clean windshield I personally own
a windshield wow this is one of the best
products for my car windshield it's the
only one that I use in fact being able
to clean both the front and the inside
window at the same time is a game Cher
which had one of these years earlier so
no more struggling to clean the inside
you need the windshield well the
windshield well applies firm cleaning
pressure for you and it's super thin to
get into all those tight dashboard areas
so what are you waiting for go to
windshield wow.com use code Walsh to
check out for a special discount that's
windshield wow.com use cod
Walsh now today another clip from a
different high school debate has gone
viral and here a student reported
won the debate by rejecting the assigned
topic and instead spending it entire
time attacking white people and
especially white Christians watch we
demand that white Christians be held
accountable for America's original sin
the negative continues the trend in
politics while whiteness devours the
other debating this topic is irrelevant
while Society is dominated by white
Christians even if we have something
educational to say about this topic the
political will just pray it away and
continue their mission to conquer the
world in the name of Jesus Christ the
military industrial complex has been
coupled with American Christianity the
worship of the weapons of whiteness the
United States was built to be a city
upon on a hill for white Christians
American Christianity has controlled all
aspects of politics such as justifying
slavery we solved by decoupling weapons
and warships and ending The Crusade
white Christians literally inscribe
scriptures onto their weapons worshiping
through War we want to repent for our
sins and show America's failure by
voting for us the judge will send his
signal to political leaders and condemn
Christianity and potic ends up being a
21 for Livingston the affirmative tells
me in summary and final Focus that the
role of the ballot for me is to reject
Christian militarism so at the end of
the day I'm left with deciding which
side I think is better doing a better
job rejecting Christian militarism
uh so he he
uh I said just changed the topic to
Christian militarism and he wins you
know I I I never participated in maybe
maybe surprisingly I was never in a
debate team as a as when I was in high
school um but I can remember in school
where we would have debates you know
where you would learn about how to how
to have a debate and you would have a
debate you you were and usually the way
that is would work is that there would
be an issue and often times kind of like
a boring issue but they' give you an
issue and then they would and then they
would tell you they would assign you a
position whether you agree with it or
not because it's not about whether you
agree it's like the the point here is
supposed to be can you defend in fact if
you don't agree that it's even better
can you find a way to defend this this
this uh this position matter how you
personally feel about it can you find a
way to defend it because the the point
is supposed to be about honing those
abilities and apparently they've got
completely away from that now and the
most troubling uh thing immediately of
course is the anti-white racism and that
these kids are openly and proudly
putting that on display but maybe even
more disturbing is that they have
apparently learned nothing about world
history never mind debate they blame
white Christians for justifying slavery
when in fact white Christians were by
far in a way the first to abolish
slavery the non-white non-Christian
world had to be dragged kicking and
screaming into abolition white
Christians were the ones who developed
the doctrine of human rights that the
abolition movement is based on white
Christians were the ones who patrolled
the Seas to stop slav ships if not for
white Christian slavery would still
probably be legal in many parts of the
world in fact even to this day slavery
is effectively still practiced in many
non-white non-Christian countries I
don't blame these kids for not knowing
those facts I blame the schools for not
teaching them and I also blame the
schools for inculcating the attitude on
display in all these vide
these are kids who are incapable of
engaging thoughtfully on an issue they
are not able to assess the merits of an
argument they cannot reason they cannot
think logically they cannot engage in
any kind of objective analysis of
anything they can only see the world
through the lens of the left's
victimhood doctrine it's a lens that is
perhaps less a lens and more a series of
Funhouse mirrors they are trying to
navigate intellectually but all they see
are distorted images and most of those
images are of themselves they cannot see
out into to the world they can focus
they can't focus on anything but
themselves this is how the schools which
are nothing but mechanisms for leftly
indoctrination of course train these
kids to
think now as I said we can't fault the
kids for this if I was currently 16
years old and I had spent essentially my
entire life up until that point in a
government indoctrination facility and
if I didn't have parental guidance at
home to counteract that indoctrination I
would be saying all of the same things
that these kids are saying and so would
you and I'd be looking at the world the
same way that they look at it pretty
much everything they hear and see and
experience every day is designed to
condition them this way it is a
Relentless brainwashing campaign that
will inevitably have a near 100% success
rate that's what we're watching here
which is why I will not cancel these
high school Debaters no matter how awful
they are at debating instead it is
everyone else responsible for turning
them into this especially the school
system itself that is today
canceled if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed